If you have a third nipple.
Please don’t show it to me.
Actually no I am totally curious.
The scientific name for your ex’s third
nipple is a supernumerary nipple.
According to the NIH, supernumerary nipples
are apparently quite common.
Exact numbers vary but it’s estimated about
1% of the population have them.
Usually people don’t have more than one
extra nipple, but this man had seven total
nipples.
SEVEN.
Most peoples’ just look like little moles,
some are clearly nipples and some even lactate
during pregnancy!
Typically, extra nipples are found along the
milk lines, also known as mammary lines, which
run from the armpits to the inner thighs.
In early human embryonic stages, clusters
of cells clump together along the milk lines.
For most people, two of these clumps will
become breasts.
Usually any extra clumps regress but sometimes
they don’t and they become extra nipples,
areolas and even full breasts.
While most extra nipples exist along these
lines, about 5% are found elsewhere, and have
a different name: ectopic supernumerary nipples.
One woman had an entire breast form on her
back, along with several nipples!
Another woman had a nipple and areola on the
bottom of her foot!
These supernumerary nipples and the accompanying
tissue can be located pretty much anywhere,
your arms, legs, face, even vulva or perineum.
All these extra nipples are rated on a scale,
which may sound like some immature game but
it’s a real thing.
I promise.
It’s Kajava’s classification, look it
up.
They can range from a complete nipple with
breast tissue, breast tissue with no nip,
simple areolas that look like moles, or even
just a patch of hair.
In most cases, extra nurples are harmless
and go unnoticed, but some people choose to
have them removed.
Especially women at high risk of breast cancer,
as these additional nipples are susceptible
to many of the same diseases regular breast
tissues are.
There has been considerable controversy about
whether supernumerary nipples are associated
with more serious conditions like renal and
urinary tract malformations, but all-in-all,
it seems like they’re pretty harmless and
just some weird, extra body part to show off
at parties.
Maybe you’ve got an extra nipple, maybe
it has a name, maybe your little friend should
have its own website.
When you buy a domain name from Domain Dot
Com, you’re taking the first steps in creating
an identity and vision for your brand.
No domain extension will help tell your story
like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
You can buy ExtraNips dot com for ten bucks.
Seriously.
Get 20% off Domain Dot Com’s already affordable
domain names and web hosting when you use
coupon code SEEKER at checkout.
Double jointedness is another cool party trick,
but how exactly does that work?
Find out in this video here.
How many times do you think we said “nipples”
in this episode?
Let us know down in the comments, be sure
to like this video and come back for more
Seeker. You can also come find us on twitter @Seeker, or me, @tracedominguez
Do not tweet me your third nipple pics!